Speaker 1: I'm going to admit to you, I'm
almost a little bit starting to think about
maybe feeling kind of bad for the failed former
President Donald Trump.
Look at the people that are into interviewing
him lately.
Look at the sorts of appearances he's doing
where he can't even be bothered to put a camera
in front of his face.
He's quite literally just phoning it in.
And even with the friendliest interviewers
just making a complete and total fool of himself.
Low energy interviews where Trump just tells
a lot of the same lies he's told for a while.
But you can tell even his heart's not even
really in the lies.
And the themes are delusion and the rewriting
of history.
Confusion in many cases, as well as weaponized
narcissism.
Trump appeared yesterday calling in, of course,
on Real America's Voice.
And it's just bizarre that he's still trying
to get away with these same tired lies.
The host is completely friendly, and Trump
still can't figure out a way to seem like
a normal person.
Here is Trump weighing in on the investigation
into him.
Trump says they should drop the investigation
into what I did with all those classified
documents because of the 12 documents that
were left behind by Joe Biden somewhere that
his lawyers immediately found and contacted
the presidential and NRA National Archives.
Listen to this.
Speaker 2: And you, of course, have been facing
this situation with the special prosecutor.
How does this change the equation with what
you've been doing with the Justice Department
to.
Speaker 1: Get this man?
And remember, the question is, how does the
Biden thing change your situation?
The answer is not at all.
Speaker 3: Well, I think it totally changes.
I mean, he's again, he's under this federal
act.
It's very tough.
And I'm under I, I was perfect under the Presidential
Records Act.
We were negotiating with NARA.
Now, you know, now is a far left group of
people.
That's not true.
I don't know if you know or if you've ever
heard.
They've red flags, essentially red flag, the
Constitution of the United States of America.
But it's a dangerous document and this is
what we're dealing with.
These are people that, uh, you know, look,
they have some real difficulties.
Speaker 1: So, listen, first of all, if you
are accused of murder and then someone else
gets accused of murder, they don't stop investigating
you.
They investigate both of you.
And maybe of the two people accused of murder.
One person did the thing and the other didn't.
The fact that Trump is being investigated
for taking at his direction tons of documents
down to Mar a Lago, trying to avoid returning
them, hiding them, moving them on and on and
on, the fact that Trump is accused of that
has no connection whatsoever to the fact that
a few documents were found by Biden's lawyers.
They immediately called the National Archives
and said, we've got to get these back to you.
Investigate Biden for that.
I'm fine with that, as I've said yesterday.
But number one, it has no connection to anything
that Trump is accused of doing.
And number two, look at the differences in
how they handled it.
As we talked about yesterday, Trump then weighing
in on the new speaker.
And Trump, I guess, tries to make the case
that he deserves the credit for.
Kevin McCarthy being speaker.
Speaker 3: Came down to crunch time.
You know, you had 20 people that were pretty
hard line and they happened to be very good
friends of mine.
Almost all of them, I would say.
All of them.
Right.
And I would make them calls, I mean, because
I didn't like what was happening.
John.
It was starting to look a little bit chaotic.
It was starting to look a little bit not good,
you think?
Right.
And what happened is I started calling them
and I started getting people to agree with
me and coming on board.
Right.
And as you know, Matt Gaetz is a very good
guy and he's you know, he's a strong guy.
And I called him big, strong guy.
Speaker 1: And he was crying.
And when I spoke to him.
Speaker 3: And I mean, it was just about over
where they were going to leave.
And I think that if they left, think of it,
if they left and you had two and a half, three
days in between.
I don't know that anything would have ever
you might have ended up with a Democrat, to
be honest with you.
Speaker 1: Trump wants us to believe that
were it not for him, not only would McCarthy
not be speaker, maybe Hakeem Jeffries would
be the speaker.
Speaker 3: Know that this thing ever would
have gotten done.
You moderates would have left other people.
It would have been a disaster.
Right?
And that's when Matt ran up to the front of
the room and he said, I'm changing my vote.
I'm changing my vote.
And he's a great guy.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, understand that after Trump issued a
not quite full throated endorsement of Kevin
McCarthy for House Speaker, it took like 12
more rounds of voting before McCarthy ultimately
became the speaker.
And if we learned anything from the speaker
vote, it's not how much power Trump still
has, it's how diminished his power actually
is.
Trump then, of course, weighed in on one of
his favorite topics COVID and favorite insofar
as he loves to claim he did great on handling
COVID when he was president.
He did not do great.
Speaker 3: And then we got hit with COVID.
We had to help the people with COVID.
You know, we would have done that.
This country would have.
I don't think it would have existed.
Right.
It was.
We did a great job with COVID.
I've always felt that, you know, people give
me a lot of credit in foreign policy on the
economy.
No, they don't.
But they they don't like doing it on COVID.
I think I did among the best jobs on COVID
because all of a sudden something came in
that nobody had any idea what it was.
Right.
And we knew it was killing a lot of people.
And, you know, I closed it to China.
Speaker 1: So now COVID was serious in retrospect.
I remember 15 cases will soon be zero.
Don't be afraid of it.
It's fine now.
It's Oh, it was terrible.
And I really handled it well.
Speaker 3: A lot of people didn't want me
to do that.
Almost nobody wanted that was that saved a
lot of lives.
But, you know, the COVID thing, obviously,
we had to go.
Guns are blazing with with the money and we
had no choice.
Otherwise, You know, we had to.
Speaker 1: Remember 15 cases will soon be
zero.
What about injecting bleach?
Don't don't don't be afraid of it.
The shutdowns are worse than the disease.
On and on and on.
And the truth is, the proof is in the outcome.
World leaders who handled COVID well were
all ease, are easily reelected, and there
is no doubt that Trump would have been reelected
if he, from the beginning had said, This is
really serious and we're going to do the best
job by being the most aggressive here.
Let's all wear our masks.
We're going to offer you MAGA masks that you
can buy.
Let's all do all these things.
Instead, they went after an 80 year old doctor.
That's that's the approach that they ended
up taking.
Okay.
Last thing, Trump wants HANNITY to write so
that HANNITY can get the Pulitzer and I guess
bring back some prestige to an award Trump
believes is no longer prestigious.
Speaker 3: And he sued them again to get the
Pulitzer Prize for Russia, Russia, Russia
reporting.
And, you know, the prize reads to the effect
on your great and brilliant reporting in Russia.
Well, they got it wrong.
It was the exact opposite.
You should get the Pulitzer Prize.
Yeah.
Sean HANNITY should start writing a little
bit and get the.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: Hey, you guys and Sara.
Yes, I can't.
It was a group of people that got it right.
Right.
The beginning.
And yeah, and, you know, I'm suing Pulitzer
now because I'm saying you got to take the
bullets.
Speaker 1: I'm assuming bullets are now, you
know, completely deranged and delusional.
And I mean, listen, how about just do the
George Santos claim that you got the Pulitzer
Prize and the Nobel Peace Prize and whatever
else, a Purple Heart and you lived in the
belly of a whale.
Just claim that you did this stuff.
But very, very strange.
Trump deflated, Trump confused, Trump disoriented,
but as narcissistic as ever, even in his rewriting
of history.
Maybe at some point soon, he'll show his face
in one of these interviews.
That would be an interesting thing to see.
But for a guy who criticized Joe Biden for
campaigning from his basement, Trump's barely
left his house since he announced he was running
in 2024 back in November.
Very strange stuff.